Welcome in.
I bought the DLC.
I bought with my own money.
This stream is not sponsored unlike the previous, the first
one.
I don't have to be so proper.
No.
I was honest in the first straight two.
What's it like being small enough to be carried like a
backpack IRL?
I wouldn't know.
That Minto...
Toot toot on the floor.
What the hell does that mean?
What does that mean?
That was a sentence.
That made no sense.
Are you sure?
Hello, Mito, and Ibo's like you!
Thank you for introducing me to this game.
My timeline has been so...
Has been so much cute.
Diana Art, and it's wonderful.
Nice.
Hooked like a ghostfish.
So are we.
This game rocks.
It's so good, though.
Grip gun.
Hot dog.
Hot dog indeed.
What the heck?
Wait, it came with a BGM?
I didn't know that.
I only got it for the outfits.
Change of plans, I'm going to SmashCon after all and we'll
be...
Wait, no!
No way!
You are!
Two years ago, I bought Katsu, thank you!
I've figured it out, we are HU-Man.
HU-Diana, HU-Diana, HU-Diana, HU-Diana, HU-Diana, HU-Diana,
HU-Diana, HU-Diana, HU-Diana.
HU-Man.
Talk to Calvin to change your BGM, Diana will have a special
gesture for each track listed above we got jazz we've got
jazz baby
yippee mint thank you for two years on go thank you dark
noodles welcome back thank you 16 months i can't believe
that some of you guys are getting two years two year
memberships like that's actually kind of insane to me like
giants i love the one that gives her goggles the the
mechanic outfit i'm not gonna lie i bought it for that
outfit it's so like she has the twin tails and the goggles
it's peak it's actually peak
time flies with me though two years of flown by they really
have i can't believe it i actually can't believe it there's
no way i often think like oh yeah i came back like last year
no way no way craziness hope you're having an amazing day
night to love your content thank you captain i really
appreciate it thank you thank you oh my gosh so many people
coming back so many people 24 months thank you i'd be at two
years if youtube didn't delete random that happens i've
heard that happens to some people so strange oh i really
appreciate so many people sticking around for so long holy
moly green green green
hey i'm new but you're here for the ace combat for oh geez
okay i'll do my best two years thank you but also thanks for
coming to watch pragmata thanks for coming to watch yeah
yeah yeah oh geez i'm excited to be playing this again
though um again first stream was sponsored by i chose to
keep playing and i also was like hey um wait i don't know if
you guys have seen them.
But I was like, hey, you got any more of those sick PR
packages that you sent to creators?
The Pragmata PR package?
Have you guys seen it?
Oh my gosh.
I mentioned it before in the previous stream, but Capcom
does not play with their PR packages.
Like it's so crazy.
Limu got one.
I'm so jealous.
I was like, hey, can I get one, please?
I'm begging.
here they're actually so cool um uh the first one i got was
a ace attorney one and it came with a gavel with my name
engraved on it which is insane um and then i got a monster
hunter wilds one that came in a literal wooden crate it came
with a full like jacket like a very heavy duty jacket it
came with a leather like custom bound notebook and uh and
like a little leather pouch and a tapestry that has my name
on it like oh my gosh cabin scared me holy cow
i didn't even know i showed up Oh my god.
But yeah.
But the Pragmata one is like a little box and you have to
like plug it in.
It's like electric and it like opens up and then another box
comes out that has little goodies in it and stuff.
It is so cool.
I saw, I saw a video of it and I was like, I, please,
please.
So I thought, thank you so much for the gift and thank you.
Mint bribe me.
I, you know, I, um, the Monster Hunter one is so awesome.
But I've, you know, thought about like giving it away to
like a bigger Monster Hunter fan.
Because even though it's like so, so cool, um, the crate is
so huge it's so huge and it's so heavy it's it's so
impressive though because it's like it's got all like the
logo like monster hunter logo on it like man i've seen like
other pr packages and they like send you swag and it's cool
and whatever but like capcoms again i'm not sponsored this
time but i'm just like glazing them but it's so their stuff
is really nice genuinely genuinely like they they it feels
like they care you know it's really nice
would the box fit a minke i don't think so it did come with
a little plushie in it
capcom have been on a great run this year truly though
actually i wonder i'm sure they sent out resident evil ones
i wonder what they were like I didn't see anyone that got
one.
What was the plushie?
I don't know.
Two years, Amito, thank you.
This title screen is so adorable, isn't it?
They're just chilling.
It's so relaxing, too.
A loaded revolver and Leon picks.
I can't tell if you're serious or not.
I can't tell if you're serious.
or not super pretty game i i i don't recall turning down any
of the graphic settings but i bet this game would look
really nice on ps5 i was like man i almost wish i'd they
sent me a uh steam key but i almost wish they had sent me a
a version for ps5 It'd be so nice looking.
It's a well-optimized game.
It is!
It is, right?
We've had no issues.
Yahoo!
Pretty sure that Alan Wake 2 had a great package that
involved an ARG.
No way!
Really?
Oh my gosh!
That would be so cool!
Margo, thank you so much for the five.
Gifted!
Would it look any better on PS5, though?
I don't know.
That's why I'm wondering.
Looks great, and it runs so smoothly.
I love it.
Games that just run...
Oh, he's back.
I'm the man.
Games that just run smoothly.
It's so funny because, you know, I often play indie games so
often.
It's like...
Oof.
Which...
you know obviously it's you can't really fault indie
developers compared to a massive company but you know it
does feel pretty refreshing to get a game and being like oh
yeah i started it up i mean especially if they're bioshock
um oh my gosh it's not sponsored anymore so i some people
were wondering with my like last stream like i didn't have
my my opening video going you know and um basically like you
know you have to be careful with like mentioning other ips
and things and my opening video has like when i'm walking
through akiba has a bunch of other ips and stuff like shown
so just to be careful you know i had to hide it now i can
talk about how going from bioshock to this has been like a
breath of fresh air Ah, ah, yes.
Makes sense.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's always those kinds of stipulations.
Steiner was tripping about it.
What is this guy talking about?
Why is he bringing up my business with you guys?
What is he doing?
What is he saying in, like, the Discord?
Next play Vampire, the Masquerade?
Why?
He's lonely.
That guy is kind of lonely.
Bioshock is good, but it definitely shows its age.
They're lying, Mint.
They're liars.
Then how did they know?
How did they know?
Steiner knows Steining.
We are truthers.
I will always be on Ibu side.
Just saying.
I will never be on Steiner's side.
Hell yeah.
Ibu side.
I feel like hold on I want to move over a little bit if I'm
blocking wait hmm oh wait
I'm blocking Diana a little too much she's too cute to be
hidden behind me
is that why you couldn't make a metal gear reference for the
first boss yes and why I was like
Keep it in!
Don't say it.
Don't spray it.
Yeah.
Impressive restraint.
Took every ounce of energy you had in you.
I almost turned back into like a little orb of energy.
I almost lost all of my spiritual energy that...
allows me to have a human form
Conceal don't feel don't let them know Were we okay to
reference it?
Oh, yeah, of course Basically anytime someone would
reference something I just don't say it out loud But you
guys cannot be silenced
You're free now.
I'm free now.
I'm a free minkey.
Space dad.
Is it true if you collect all?
Don't say that.
All mintorbs you can wish for anything you want.
Why would it be one or another number, huh?
Why would it be one or another number?
How would you not know that it's one exact number.
It would not be four or five orbs.
You would know that it is five orbs, no?
Lemelie, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Say it.
I won't.
I won't give you the satisfaction.
I won't give you the satisfaction of me saying the funny
numbers.
What if I said six or nine orbs?
That's not funny anymore, is it?
That's not the... Those aren't the funny numbers anymore.
Nice.
We've lost our way.
Thanks for not referencing Metal Gear for two hours, Minto.
I know that took a lot of restraint.
It did.
Thank you, Gubbo.
7 times 7 equals 49 I think is a new one what what never
heard that before you are on the you are on the the the the
battlegrounds of a new emerging please no more number memes
right I can't see I can't keep looking at numbers and being
like oh no i can't say eventually i'm gonna run out of
numbers i can say tricking the gen alphas to do math they
want to make math funny there's some teacher out there being
like i've done it the children are saying numbers the
children are are interested in the
No more number memes?
What is 10 minus 4?
With all the hacking in this game, surely you're okay with
Leet?
Oh, sorry, that was my controller disconnecting.
Yeah, bring back Leet.
Oh yeah, sorry, I forgot to say.
Keikaku means plan.
Trucker code.
Yeah.
Would you recommend Pragmata or Tomodachi, Minto?
Those are two very vastly different games.
I think I would recommend both.
Oh.
But it also is like, what kind of game do you want?
Do you want the game where you are determining people
people's fate or do you want shooting him that depends on
what genre would you recommend animal crossing or fantasy
live i really like fantasy life i haven't finished the new
one though
um actually to get tomodachi life on my switch i had to
archive some games i didn't have enough space and the first
thing was like hey you want to archive that fantasy life you
haven't touched it a couple months hey it's been three
months since you last played fantasy life loser yeah i do
really like fantasy life though it's one of those like kind
of satisfying games where i could just like like basically
if you don't know you you can you assign your there's a
story but then also you can assign yourself different uh
jobs so you can be like a cook and you can be a timber man
and you can be a fisherman and you can be a paladin man
paladin man paladin man pal it can be and then there's
different types you can be a wizard man and um you like
explore areas but you have to like you know level up your to
cut the cut the bigger tree you have to level up and stuff
oh you can grind to max level it's one of those types of
games can i be human no can i be paladin girl yes
still need to do my homework watching part one of this game
but this week's schedule is a banger thank you oh no i can't
stop yawning i didn't fall asleep until 4 a.m yesterday
liar.
Can I be your man?
That's a good one.
You were up late, too.
What were you doing?
I cast sleep upon you.
I cast... I almost said eternal sleep.
Boy, that's kind of bad.
I cast a good rest upon you.
Good upon ye I cast sweet dreams I cast full
nights rest oh by the way I'm not a wizard so I actually
don't know what I'm sending to you it might be frogs who
knows could literally be anything I cast honk me me me me me
me me you're casting unlicensed spells don't tell the
ministry of magic they'll they'll take my my I've got a
nasty headache and I have to teach a bunch of very loud
stick fighting Tonight, can I get a headache away, Beam?
No, not to sleep.
Oh, headache, bad.
Or singlet's face.
Feel better.
Beep.
What's stick fighting?
What is that?
Kendo?
Or?
Good night from the UK.
Good night, user, Tindo.
You fight with sticks.
LARPing?
Spaces goes, thank you!
Like those old flash animations.
Fighting with sticks.
Who, what is, what do you teach the art of stick fighting?
Don't give it a fancier title than what it is.
You are larping.
You are live action role playing.
You wouldn't get it.
Casting rest spells while I'm trying to fight jet lag.
Oh, oof.
Wait, are you trying to stay awake or?
Oh, I guess you would be right.
I guess this is how everyone finds out I'm half Filipino.
Eskrim.
Hold on, I'm Googling that.
How do you say that?
Eskrim.
Whoa!
Filipino weapon-based martial arts.
art what i said it right wait which time wow they really are
sticks oh my god wait it's sticks and knives i cast you
eskrima eskrima today i learned Whoa!
That seems like, okay, tell, like, I feel like this is kind
of the most practical type of, you know, like if you're
learning a martial arts that requires a weapon, wouldn't
learning something that requires just a stick be so, like,
helpful?
Someone comes to rob you.
Oh no, I have no, I have no weapon.
What do I do?
Grab a stick.
I think running away works best.
What if they're faster than you?
That's kind of why it was invented, right?
Oh no, I'm being robbed right in front of this store that
has sticks only Oh, no, I'm being robbed in front of this in
the forest there's only sticks
The stick store They sell sticks and walking sticks.
Wait, you never built yourself a house out of sticks?
Did I... I forgot to mention that the store is owned by the
Three Little Pigs?
We do sticks, knives, thrown weapons, and hands!
I learned today.
That's so cool.
Thanks for teaching me.
I've never heard of this before.
Sorry for saying you were larping.
Only one of the pigs used sticks.
Yeah, and then he realized how lucrative of a martial arts
business it could be.
Yeah, rude.
24Q!
Better stick to it.
Oh my gosh, why can't I stop yawning?
Okay, we should play the game then, so I stop yawning,
right?
I want to see...
How do I put on my new outfits?
figure it out.
She's so eepy!
Hello!
Love it, we can bring stuff back to this.
Yeah, me too.
What's up, Hugh?
Anything I can help you with?
If I ever need some help, I'll be sure to let you know.
Cool, I think we have our dialogue with her.
This must be it, right?
Yeah!
Wait, so I like the cat suit for him.
It kind of, he looks like, he becomes, uh...
Actually, I think I like the original a bit more.
He becomes, uh, John Halo.
Heavy lifter is cool, too.
It looks like Bumblebee.
Yeah, Master Chief.
Master Chief Cat.
My headaches definitely gone after that.
Thanks, Minky!
There's nothing wrong with LARPing.
It's just not my bag.
I'm glad I could help.
What's this one, though?
Oh, exchange cabin coins.
Okay.
I don't know.
I really like the Delphi suit.
Delphi.
We'll try the cat suit, though, too.
It is pretty cute.
And then, of course, for Diana.
This one is very cute, obviously.
But I don't like so much that it hides her hair.
this though oh precious so adorable the little twin tails
the goggles the suit it's so cute I'm a fan what thing what
is it drawing was so much fun that I I kind of made a mess.
Do matching outfits?
Okay.
We'll match.
It does look good.
All of the suits look good.
I think the original is actually my favorite, though, which
is kind of crazy.
This one's okay.
This one's probably my least favorite.
Hmm.
She's so stinky.
Oh, it looks so good on her!
Diana, if you ever need anything, let me know.
Need?
All I really need to function is a power source.
Aside from that.
It looks so good.
Oh.
Cute, cute, cute.
Yeah.
Diana, so cute.
Anyone getting bumblebee vibes?
100%.
It's orange bumblebee.
last left off um we unlocked a new area very exciting what
is this oh art book oh my gosh wait i probably shouldn't go
through some of these no maybe maybe some of this would be
spoilers right oh wait so cute so cute there are some
spoilers maybe spoilers
Orange chappy.
Okay.
I'll stop here.
There's 75!
Holy cow.
Yeah, so...
Hoi.
I honestly though, and I know I said this yesterday.
But depending on how this game goes, I really think it could
be nominated for Game of the Year.
Dress her up as Wally!
Wally!
Eva!
Let's see.
Shall we go then?
You can definitely see it as a contender.
It's so nice to just get an original IP that people really
end up like gravitating towards.
It's really nice.
Oh, it feels so good.
Isn't GTA 7 coming out this year?
I have no idea.
Certain that'll be nominated, winning, not sure.
There is a lot of competition.
That is true.
I know, right?
GTA 6.
Oh, 6.
Someone said I was just reading it.
year after six trust
skipping six yeah they were like oh we we don't know we
don't know if we can if we can live up to everybody's
expectations alright I believe I did kind of already do the
loadout yeah we did like my hacking node this was the multi
hack I can't wait to try this eating my guitar Thank you so
much for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I heard ignoring Diana can lead to a bad ending.
What kind of a monster would do that?
Let's go on the tram to the mass production array.
I have to remember how to hack.
Who could ignore her?
That mentally hurt me.
deserve a bad ending for that so true it would be so sad to
ignore her all right we're back in the spooky areas
everybody what's this oh no we're fine anything oh oh
production production of what now so we're trying to now we
can go to the comps tower go to the comps tower actually get
through to earth but they need to know about my team they're
trying to go to the comms tower oh wait what was scan there
we go alright so that we can uh contact earth and go home
Diana my the best little backseater I could ever ask for
hmm whoa wow this area is giving me a portal vibes I think I
just want to play Portal.
Levycore, thank you!
Need the new Onimusha game to hit hard so we can see three
Capcom games lined up for Game of the Year.
Right.
Thank you.
Oh, what?
A cat?
Kitty cat!
Hey, wait!
can't see oh my god
oh my god the cutest thing happened the other day where um
pause she likes to sit in the window and just look out at
the world what are you doing you're trying to hurt yourself
if i break you can just fix me back up that's not the point
but you have to be more careful yeah she likes to look at
lizards oh yeah that's true why i mean well you best think
on that yourself okay i will
look at her little boots and
He's like so shaken up, actually.
Where are the people?
Even if they were, like...
Even if they were killed...
There would still be blood and stuff, no?
Like, their bodies?
Like, where are the people?
But, um, yeah.
Pause, my cat.
She likes to sit in the window and look at lizards and birds
and squirrels.
But...
The other day, she was sitting in the window and I hear...
I hear from the window, I hear a kid go, Kitty!
And she, like, started meowing at him, and she was like,
Brum, brum, brum, brum.
It's so cute.
It was, it was, I was like, oh my gosh.
My cat got noticed.
Oh, Data Shard, a fragment of data that slightly, that
slightly fills Diana's hacking gauge.
Ah, don't mind if I do.
Oh, look, a taxi!
Oh, a taxi was being printed!
I hear, like, something over there.
I think it's, like, stuff that's trying to be printed.
Wow, look at that!
But why?
Yeah, I feel like it would be so expensive to ship it back
to Earth.
Why?
Space taxi.
tell if what i'm hearing is a robot or not i remember how to
shoot i remember
okay i remember
oh i guess i didn't need that there was only one guy that's
okay though really oh he exploded we're fine Easy peasy.
Everyone is fine.
They are in the next room preparing a surprise party for
you.
With cake and everything?
Right?
Oh, there's another taxi.
So cool.
Wait, that one has an ad already printed on it.
That's crazy.
Pre-printed ad.
Anything over here?
Money?
We, oh.
Upgrades.
We take those.
Oh, no.
Just kidding.
I thought that was a thing.
ABS always be scanning.
What's this?
Area closed for testing.
Chat frozen.
I got you.
To all personnel, the mass production array uses a massive
limb replicator installed in the ceiling to test print
structures.
Capital ships and jumbo airliners.
Those are some tough words to say in a row.
Because the area will be sealed up by heavy bulkheads when
you hear an announcement, please evacuate the area
immediately.
Is that foreshadowing?
Are we going to have to evacuate immediately?
on something.
Look at that.
Oh, it's making a taxi.
Why are they only making taxis?
What is happening here?
Not the smiley faces.
Data bank access requests Pragmata.
Details.
The inquiry keyword Pragmata is classified at security level
6.
Only a summary is available for viewing.
Pragmata overview.
A high-functioning autonomous prosthetic body with a
simulated organic structure currently undergoing operational
testing in limited sectors due to differing design concepts
it is not compatible with standard work bots commonly used
throughout the cradle cradle data bank administrator I see
what is this you really can make everything a lunar filament
huh they don't have it on earth no testing's been limited to
the moon as far as I know yeah people back home have only
heard about stuff like this does that mean there are no
pragmata no clue but I'm sure as heck never seen a bot that
needs as much watching as you do is that a bad thing yeah
you keep things interesting that's good he's like so nice to
her it's so cute area three limb generated area Oh.
Holy.
Oh, oops.
Where did he come from?
Oh, from in here.
Oh, we got another decode.
Let's use this when we're outnumbered.
Wait, we want the multi-hack.
Yeah.
He came from...
He was just chilling in here.
He was just hanging out.
What is that?
Where did he go?
Internal glossary, Luna Filament.
Lunum and Luna Filament.
Oh, good.
We're getting, like, the lore of the area and everything.
During lunar exploration, the Orlunum.
Wait, was it...
What's the name?
Isn't the company in...
What's that name?
What's that show?
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
severance isn't it called lunum too you're thinking of lumen
oh close lunum was discovered accidentally through
nanomachine refinement nanomachines they yielded luna
filament a material capable of replicating structural and
functional data research at the cradle is actively exploring
its applications with expectations of driving significant
growth and breakthroughs for Delphi.
Could you make an organ with a Lunum?
Lunafilament?
I don't know about sure.
Lunum and Lunafilament.
Who names these things?
I don't think that's that crazy of a name.
It just sounds like something from...
Lunar?
It actually makes sense to me.
Sounds like something...
From the moon, no?
Repair kit.
Suit integrity is full.
You're too good at the game, maybe?
Look!
I think that's the comms tower!
It is?
Where?
There!
That big one!
Right in the middle!
Whoa.
Whoa!
What?
There's a whole city!
Looks a bit like New York.
Is that a place on Earth?
Holy cow!
How many people are here?
So many lights and signs.
I can't decide what to look at first.
Why are they sideways?
This is why they need taxis.
Wait, the taxis are all messed up, though.
Wait, this is so cool.
What?
I like the...
The road got messed up, I guess.
Wait!
Birds!
Oh my gosh, the birds are connecting our world.
Oh, I see a guy on the taxi.
What?
Look at this!
Wow!
The birds are fake, actually.
Wait, this is... What the heck happened?
R&R's donut.
Crazy dance.
The Eclipse Theater.
Oh my gosh.
What does it say?
YOLO boutique.
Crazy dance star to be replaced by understudy after twisting
ankle during rehearsals.
Oof.
Oh,
there's another one.
Why are they, like, crouching by the...
Oh, there's another one.
Ah, yeah!
Oh, we lost our gun.
How's the audio, by the way?
Because there's ads for birds everywhere.
are you good okay cool nice more ads look at this i can't
get over it it's like such a cool aesthetic
if i start ultimate protection for your digital life
solstice solar panels solstice all right let's hack this guy
I wish they didn't notice me when I start hacking them, you
know, like Leave the shooting to me
Why are they all crouched by the taxis, though?
For everyone who wants to see the cars They don't look so
like You could make anything, and they You'd think the
inside would look like a Tesla or something normal,
actually.
Anytime you need, eat and drink.
Wait, what's in there?
We got tea flavor and barbecue sauce.
Let's go.
Oh my gosh, it really is New York.
The ground is steamy.
I'm just looking around at this point.
I'm having too much fun looking.
A diner.
Oh, hack.
Can you hack?
No?
No hack?
You can't hack?
You sure?
Okay.
Where's the trash, though?
Right here.
It says eat and drink any- Oh, our favorite- spicy barbecue
burger!
Only $5.99 on the moon!
The moon has better pricing than Earth, I think.
Why?
sounds.
Oh.
Oh, that's not good.
Oh, wow.
It's locked down.
Ah, Edis again.
Uh-oh.
Damn.
So that's how it is?
Edis isn't very nice, is it?
Unlock the massive game.
Wait, we need to disable the lock codes and the local access
beacons to reach the cons tower.
Okay.
Pack the beacons.
I don't know.
Try scanning.
Wait, where did this come from?
Try scanning, she says.
Over here?
Oh, oh, we were just early.
Oh, uh...
I don't like that.
Oh, I don't like that.
It almost had us.
Yeah, nice moves, kid.
Oh, no, but we have to eventually go back outside.
Ooh, it's like crawling around.
What is this?
Oh.
Can't forget you!
Oh, yeah!
There we go.
We do have two upgrade components, but...
Yeah, just never go outside again.
So easy.
Oh.
Red zone shopping district.
extremely dangerous securing this red zone will unlock a
section of a stamp board a red gate key is required for an
entry responding to my hat oh i really want to know what's
back there challenge area it could be something good could
be something good whoa what happened here there's a beacon
right there very nice multi-hack now we can hack a bunch of
bobs at once wait I'm kind of confused oh okay I grabbed two
because I had only used one oh soup one stop souvenir whoa
everything's all messed up
wait is this inside the red zone?
I wonder what makes it so difficult.
Anyway.
Erm.
What do we got going on in here?
No.
Wait.
Yes.
What's down there?
Okay.
I'm just looking around.
Charlie.
One night only.
The sensation returns.
What does he do?
June 1st tickets now on sale the Artemis Theater oh my god
Charlie is back I'm looking at it the new musical Knights
see life beyond the realm why what is that
oh shoot oh yeah I forgot to dodge bye-bye hey Oh, shoot.
Kaplowey.
Is it because I stuck around too long?
Is it because I...
They don't like me reading.
Wait, no, no way.
Riot Blaster.
Tactical unit that fires arching conclusive rounds.
Oh!
It's like a grenade.
Cool.
grenade launcher yeah we'll swap i don't think well i feel
like the net is pretty the stasis net is also really good
but i haven't had a i i should try it on like uh on bigger
guys to see how well it works you know what i mean but also
i'm sorry resident devil this isn't really the city it's
more like your average shopping resident devil may cry there
sure has a lot of places yeah there's also a ton of stuff
you can't find on the resident devil may weep i want to see
no it's the red gate key authorization to pass through a red
zone gate special bot deployment sector secured by a edis
red zone here we come i don't know about that i don't know
about that one Maybe later.
I mean, we could see why it's so difficult.
We could, like, test it out, maybe.
You believe in me?
You believe...
Oh.
Whoa.
Oh, here's the tea flavor.
Tea flavor, royal milk.
Wait, tea flavor, sauce.
Wait, what?
Barbecue sauce cheese.
Wait, we got...
Shut up.
I love chicken and waffles.
The clucker.
They got the kitty pizza and the kitty mac and cheese.
These prices are insane.
Why are they so cheap?
The American pizza.
The madman pizza.
Brooklyn pizza.
New York cheese pizza.
Hand smashed to perfection?
Moonbucks are worth more?
Wow.
Look at the ingredients.
Crispy skin on fries.
What?
Cheese, curd, and peppercorn gravy.
Smoke, chicken, salad, choice of fries or rice.
Where's the waffle?
What?
The cluckard.
Barbecue, smoked chicken, filet, lettuce, tomato, red onion,
and crispy.
What is a crispy skin on fries, cheese, curd, and peppercorn
gravy?
What is that?
What?
Why is the mac and cheese chicken filet?
Why is
the pizza a smoke chicken with a crispy chicken or fries
cheesecracker?
It's all...
Why is the pizza come with a choice of fries or rice?
What?
Edis?
What's this though?
A little wine to wind down the day.
This place is kind of fancy.
They got condiments in there, probably.
I love a restaurant with a tiny lamp on the table.
Dante.
This is actually giving, like, almost, like, Doom poster a
little bit.
But Tara wrote that.
Of course she did.
Resident Devil.
or resident evil
resident evil
it's just pictures of Billy Eilish everywhere
oh I'm up oh oh that's a guy yay yay and we're gonna get
close and we're gonna shoot Wait!
Oh.
Running away, running away.
Oh, I gotta reload.
I really love that they put menus, ads, and other realistic
touches.
So many games just do blurred sm- That's true!
A lot of they do, right?
Like, there's actually, like, real ads here.
Oh.
Look!
There's a bunch of dolls!
all lined up right gets my gets my grenade launcher huh
hmm I heard something there's a beacon it's so close the
beacon there's got to be another way the beacon oh nice we
got another one Yeah!
Wait, what's up here?
Oh, oops.
Wait, we can do this.
Oh,
I can't get in there.
Wait, I'm stuck.
I'm actually stuck.
Ouch!
This might be a horror game.
Might be a horror game.
Wait, is this the...
What is this?
Extended breach.
Open enemies stay exposed for 15% longer.
That can help me hack better.
Yay.
Okay, uh...
Do you help me up?
Wait, actually, how do I get out of here?
Oh.
I just jumped.
Oh, I think I turned off the lasers with that.
Hopefully.
Alright, let's see what's going on here.
Hmm.
This is...
It's a mannequin.
Oh, they actually are mannequins, I think.
They might look the part, but...
real people got that lifeblood in them lifeblood i got that
dog means no moving no i mean uh humans got a certain warmth
to them oh oh oh over 36 degrees celsius right no just
forget it so they meet they meet and then sexy time then no
clothes such Interesting storytelling.
What a cool building.
Alright.
Let me go up.
Tuna!
Where is he?
Tuna?
Oh, Tuna?
Tuna!
What is he saying, actually?
What the arrow for, though?
That's kind of interesting, huh?
Okay.
Up, up, up, away we go.
Up, up, up we go.
Multi-hack.
Did I use one of these already?
Oh, I guess I grabbed another one.
Nice.
I think I heard something walking.
Holy!
Oh, that's a lot of them!
Blinking in the enemy!
Nice.
They were like, hey, Bio...
You want that multi-hack right now?
You want that...
They were literally bullies in the alleyway.
Lots of limb.
Nice.
Itadakimasu.
You want that multi-hack?
Anyone behind me?
Okay.
Someone gonna come busting through the doors of Maria?
Maybe?
I don't know.
Red Max.
Riot Blaster.
More multi-hack.
Spicy barbecue burger.
All beef, patty, jalapeno, cheddar cheese, and our famous
barbecue sauce.
Wait, that looks good.
That looks pretty.
Stinking good.
Borgor.
Wait, there's a package in there.
How do I get?
Definitely thought I heard someone else.
But I'm looking around.
Oh, that's a multi-hack.
I feel like there's probably something over there on...
Well, maybe not.
Diana's donuts.
Sorry to say this, but I don't eat burgers.
That's okay.
What if it's 3D printed?
That's, oh, ghouls and ghosts!
These ads are so funny.
But they're so, this actually feels like New York.
It's pretty funny.
Do you think I have to go, I don't want to have to go all
the way back around, go through this again.
But like, maybe I go through the, I didn't try to go into
the clothing store.
there time
square for real for real right probably
let's try it oh that's a window just kidding well there was
an attempt to the beacon first it'll open a path meh maybe
maybe are we birds maybe we might actually be birds all
right let's go down oh no I can't access the beacon with his
box in the way oh shoot oh gosh oh there's this Oh my gosh.
Ouch, ouch, there's more than one.
I think it's time to use my...
Did I use it?
No.
Please heal.
Oh shoot, oops.
Look out.
Oh my gosh.
Please heal.
There's more?
Oh my gosh.
I need you to not.
Hey, please!
Okay.
Oh, I didn't mean to press it.
We're fine.
These guys are so annoying.
The drones are so annoying!
Oh, why do I keep pressing the wrong?
Probably because I played on my Switch yesterday.
Now where?
There we go.
There!
Yippee!
Oh!
It opened another door for us.
This is gonna take forever.
Can't we just pop them all at once?
They aren't connected.
So, I don't think so.
The red zones need to be completed for the cabin stamp
cards.
Oh, they do!
Oh, man.
All right.
Oh, I thought I heard.
There was the door.
New York back then.
Standing here.
It feels like being on Earth.
as if the New York I saw as a child is ripe for my eyes.
It's not just about meeting the basic conditions for life.
We humans need landscapes that can hold our memories.
Places to call home.
Lunafilament can recreate those memories for us.
I could stay here forever.
But it sounds like Lunafilament's kind of like, um.
It's kind of like they were all memories.
This is not for me.
Why is that?
It's kind of backfiring.
It's rejecting.
It doesn't necessarily look like the moon, but I don't know.
It's just too clean here.
Earth is dirty.
But maybe I like messy.
Oh, pure Lunum.
Extremely rare high purity chunk of Lunum.
Capable of upgrading a...
Wait!
This is the special stuff that we needed.
Yeah!
Oh, lucky fine.
Yippee!
I feel though I should go back, no?
And...
Um...
Hello?
There we go.
Emergency kit that repairs minor damage to your suit.
Right now?
Is it repairing?
Is it doing the thing?
Um...
I'll probably have to go back and do the...
What's it called though, no?
The red room.
Does Earth really look like this?
You've really been left in the dark, huh?
Spooky!
Didn't anyone ever teach you this stuff?
Nope.
I was left in sleep mode for so long.
Oh, that's a window.
And when I woke up, the boat was all messed up.
Must have been the quakes.
There was no one else?
Nope.
Nobody.
All alone, huh?
The parker.
We could get it here.
That thing.
Lucky, thank you.
Look up, gamer.
I'm a gamer.
And I looked up.
Gamers don't look up.
This gamer looks up.
Oh, mannequin.
Real, actual mannequin?
Why is this mannequin like...
Oh!
Holy cow, why is this mannequin 10 feet tall?
I can't stay up to the extra log after!
It's spooky in here.
What?
Suddenly a horror game for real.
I'm just so curious why everything is the way that it is at
the moment, you know?
Like, why has everything become this way?
Data shard.
I data sharded myself.
from that news.
Alright, let's go.
Spookiness.
Spooky, spooky.
What the heck?
How...
There will be a switch somewhere.
Ew, they're all like standing upside down.
It's so creepy.
We knew this would happen at some point.
I think the rest are all mannequins real.
We knew this was going to happen.
Oh, our hacking gauge is full too.
Okay, good to know.
I think I...
What was it?
Left button?
Was it left button, right button?
Or left analog, right analog?
Or look up?
There's nothing here.
What do you mean look up?
Why is red mean scary, though?
L3, R3.
Okay, it's both.
Okay.
Oh, it does say on the UI, you're right.
Maybe I go this way.
Ah, here it is.
Got it!
Ooh, that was close.
That was close, close.
We got...
Oh!
Cabin' coin!
People enjoying the robot daughter's drawings just prove
that people would be okay with AI art so long as they like
the robot that made it.
I missed though back when a time when robots were fun and
not compared to AI when it was like oh yeah I have a robot
companion like even even like it feels like you're not even
allowed to use your like google home anymore or anything
thanks for the inspiration me though it's my birthday Ruka
happy birthday great stream, great day and all the best.
Is that a squirrel?
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Mini mannequin.
Mini, mini mannequin.
Mini, mini.
Are you guys afraid of mannequin?
I'm not actually, but I don't want to be jump scared by a...
Oh, I see him.
You're literally not fooling anybody.
You can't even stand still.
What are you trying?
Who are you trying to fool?
Can I go up here?
Doesn't seem like it.
Who are you trying to fool?
Hmm?
Well,
we got one guy.
They knew you would see him.
They were like, uh-uh.
We haven't something.
We have another fella up our sleeve.
Why won't the ladies talk to me?
Got more money.
Oh, dogs!
This game is complete.
This game is complete!
Yeah!
Interesting room.
Thanks for the hot dogs!
Close quarters.
CQC?
Increased attack power by 10% within...
Win within 10 meters of the enemy.
Fun.
I wonder what weapons that have worked with.
That's such a great question.
the space dad and hot dog finder what is your wisdom of the
day it's a great game if there's a hot dog in it oh another
repair kit let's go urban recreation project this project
which recreates iconic oh also if I sometimes I miss the
emails on these things so if I do miss one just let me know
if you're like go back and read you miss the email you miss
the second part this project which recreates iconic
cityscapes from major cities such as New York, Seoul,
Madrid, and Delhi is an unprecedented large-scale output
test.
At the same time, it aims to prove that Luna filament can
enable rapid urban development, showcasing its value on
Earth and paving the way for future projects.
Forward forward, return to Earth request from Tul Anki from
Eileen.
test on purpose?
Wow, that never even crossed my mind.
If I can't handle the conditions here, no way they'd make me
stay, right?
Thanks for the tip.
I got my test tomorrow, so I'll give this a try.
Hope this gets me back to Earth.
Do the people not want... There's several people not wanting
to be here, it seems.
That's a couple people trying to return to Earth for
whatever reasons.
Very interesting.
Thank you.
Oh, shoot.
Isn't that really big guy around here?
Dead hunter.
I hear like...
Oh, jalapeno, jalapeno, jalapeno.
All beef, patty, cheddar cheese.
And our famous barbecue sauce!
Spicy burger, barbecue, burger, barbecue.
Spicy barbecue burger!
What is this doing?
Oh, that's convenient.
Oh, that is convenient.
Oh my god, it's literally like crawling around down there.
Don't fall.
You'll really regret it.
Ew, they're like zombies waiting down there.
Ew.
All right.
But no cats this time.
Aw.
I don't need you crawling off the side of the bridge going
after it again.
got it i won't do that okay this goes up here good to know
in case we do fall best think on that yourself see i can do
that first think on that yourself one for word because i
wrote what you said in my memory course i think we should go
back though i think we should return to the shelter and do
some upgrades we can always go back actually wasn't the last
there was the other one that was right next to the the red
room so
I'll clear no box in sight
the replicator bridges are so cool did I change their
outfits I did wouldn't it be fun if there were replicator
bridges everywhere that's how you end up with more bridges
than roads what's wrong with bridges yeah death stranding
hate special you do you have any children no no kids for me
i'm not married either yeah i thought that was the case what
are you trying to say i'm pretty content with my life if
that's what you're asking didn't you say before that you
don't like kids did i say something bad no you're fine as
you get older sometimes stuff just gets to you just drop it
yeah what's that supposed to mean you can i go outside to
play some time are you crazy going out by yourself is asking
for trouble what if a bot comes for you i wouldn't be able
to stop i wonder why the bots are after her too though
together you will keep me safe choose sure thing they see in
that case i'll keep playing in the shelter then
as far as I can tell you don't look like an old model so why
the heck were you in storage yeah I don't know maybe they
just didn't need me anymore or or maybe I just wasn't good
enough no yeah that's a hey don't worry about it you know
yep doesn't bother me oh that reminds me Diana everything we
print from the REM replicator is yours Really?
Everything?
Yeah.
Seeing all this stuff before, anyways.
Can't have too many toys, right?
Yeah.
I've never had toys before.
So cute.
Thanks, Hugh.
You cute.
I'm gonna give you all the toys.
I gotta get through Christmas.
Christmas.
There it is.
There what is?
What is she looking for?
Oh, this again.
Drawing was so much fun.
that I kind of made a mess.
Oh, whoops, that's not what I meant to press.
I meant to look at them.
We got a new one.
We got this tuna.
Oh my god!
He's got his little show mask on.
So cute!
Do you know I get the REM replicator blueprint before
leaving the first section?
I don't think I got one.
Maybe I did, and I didn't realize.
No, I didn't!
Wait.
Where was it?
I feel like I'm pretty good at looking around.
Maybe it's in the room?
The bedroom?
Maybe?
I have seven golden cubes.
Let's upgrade my suit.
Yes.
And my damage?
Yeah.
Yes!
And we can do two more.
We'll do my suit.
We'll keep...
Wait.
Hmm.
Do we want to get...
Let's get everything to level 5.
We'll keep it nice and even.
Nice and level.
Yeah.
Sorry, Diana.
I focused on you so much last time.
If you want to look for REM, you can look at the map and
it'll show you.
Oh, okay.
Now I have seven shots!
Nice.
And we got this bad boy here too.
Uh...
Can be equipped at the tram terminal.
Enemy down time up.
We got the abilities.
Critical shot.
Or faster moves.
Slow down time.
letting you press whoa this one's sick though it's like a
finisher both are good yeah it's like a perfect dodge for
sure I do wonder if I'll how well I'll do it how well I'll
do it there's also we can get another node slot
hmm hmm
you do have to dodge to begin with I dodge Doge!
You do quite...
You do good dodges quite often, I feel like.
Yeah?
Let's do...
Finisher
might be good for bigger bots.
We could try it, the critical shot.
We'll get another one, surely, eventually, sometime.
Somewhere.
Node spawn right.
Wait, unlocks critical.
When an enemy's health is low, a critical shot node may
appear.
Passing through it during a hack.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Like the point, the point, though.
Letting impress our team to perform a point blank shot.
Do not spawn.
Does not spawn against certain strong enemies, though.
It does say that.
Save it for Pragvata 2.
Yeah, I gotta save all my points for the next game.
You guys, you're so right.
Ah, yeah, yeah, you're so right.
Basically, it won't spawn against main bosses.
The description isn't quite accurate.
Upgrading increases the health threshold where the critical
shot node appears.
Maybe I should get the fast moves then.
I'll get that.
I'll get the fast moves.
We can try the critical shot.
Or, I don't know.
It's so tricky, right?
I feel like I would...
So basically, it's like if you hack again
when their health is low enough, right?
Not that...
I guess it helps you not have to shoot?
Or it doesn't seem like you're shooting.
You're, like, doing a...
Like, what if I need to reload, right?
Crit shot gives eye frames.
Oh, wait.
That's kind of nice though.
Hmm.
We'll do the critical shot then.
We'll do the style over function.
Ah!
Ooh.
And we can upgrade it.
I'll upgrade it.
Nice.
I also will upgrade
I'm thinking my repair up.
You think that was a good choice?
Me too.
I went with crit first too.
Was very satisfied.
Oh, nice.
Sure sounds good.
Does.
Yeah, this is more HP per heal.
Which we don't get so much, honestly.
I think the health would probably be good to get.
We could get another one.
Or I could...
The way he like flopped to the floor is so funny.
Oh wait.
Decode.
Hacking node that disrupts enemy internal systems.
Temporarily decreasing damage dealt.
Mint device had said...
I only played MGSV, TPP, and loved it.
I had a recently started playing Delta.
Would I be safe or would I be crucified?
You have been judged and your sentence is 20 hours of
community service.
Fair enough.
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
Don't say, what are you doing here?
Go play the rest.
No, I don't...
Watch the stream, and then you can play the game.
Or have the stream on while you play.
Don't tell people to leave.
Don't tell people to leave the stream.
Wait a second.
I need you guys here.
Don't tell people.
Okay, I think I might actually get this decode one.
I think it's kind of nice to have temporarily increasing
damage.
Wait, what's it?
Oh, it's that one!
Okay, I see it.
Wait.
Never mind.
We have this already.
I'm a silly.
I was thinking of something else.
We could do more mod slot.
Hacking.
Or I could just save my money.
I can't decide right now.
I forgot also.
We have new BGM.
And we have our stamp club.
bought data we are honored to provide one of our greatest
goods that puts it in your loadout
so we need uh now i see the lock section ah i see i see i
see i see i see i see i see okay okay
we now have lofi
I need you guys here My Oshi is horribly codependent on her
chat This is troubling The first red gate is not that tough
Worth a try Yeah I think I was gonna go try it right after
this Because I just wanted to heal Let's try EDM Wait EDM is
gonna go hard no
Why didn't Why couldn't the The DLC come with an OST Oh look
at Diana Oh Oh, you're right.
Let's see what she does.
For your patronage.
She does have dances, doesn't she?
Dance for me.
She has no idea where she is right now.
Oh!
Yeah!
Oh yeah!
Bring it around!
Who programmed this into her?
Someone was like, she has to know how to dance.
Look at her footprint on the ground.
That's so interesting.
Why is it like that?
Oh wait.
Sorry, my head is blocking it.
Can you see it?
Bring it all around.
And jump
a ball.
Jump, jump, jump,
jump, jump, jump, jump.
Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
Let's see the other songs.
Wait, we didn't do the lo-fi version.
Let's see what she does here.
We wish you a happy Shelter life.
Diana's my Oshi now.
I don't blame you.
I can do the same thing as her though.
Oh.
She looks so sad.
Is she falling asleep?
Oh, she's falling asleep.
This game is legit so cute.
I know.
I can't get enough of it.
I'm so happy.
Diana is at the Wiggles concert right now.
Let me get her go.
She's like, fruit, salad.
Yummy, yummy.
Alright, let's see our last song.
We haven't even heard the jazz one though.
Shelter jazz!
We wish you a happy shelter life.
Come on.
Give us a shimmy.
She's feeling it.
No way that is a jazz square!
Let's go!
Oh!
We're going to get a shuffle ball change.
Oh, Jazz Square.
Yes.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
She's getting it.
She's so cute.
Who taught her that?
Me.
I taught her that.
Woo.
Oh, oh, it's okay.
Nobody saw.
Actually, I was looking away.
This is actually what I looked like when I did...
When I took Jazz at her age.
When I did tap and Jazz at her age, tap and Jazz dance
classes.
This is exactly what I looked like.
Oh yeah!
Oh!
Yeah!
Oh, this looks like what like our routines would be, like
our warm-up routines would be.
Except the song would be Oh gosh If I heard it I would know
it But because I'm listening to other jazz I can't think of
it at the moment It's like a famous jazz song though Sector
got Wow He's got one single Ball
Cool Wait It's open That's so aesthetically pleasing he's
just like jojo leon um okay let's go oh she's drawing
somewhere the earth drawing on a screen is fun but nothing
beats the feel of okay we are blasted the music in here i
can't hear you can speak up oh yeah have you heard about
color the girl that hold on i'll say it after i can't choose
i like all of them all right no rush i can't hear you over
the sound of the saxophones i'll let you know there was this
girl that loved a specific yellow crayon it was like the
daffodil i think color and she like made it her life like
she would go to like thrift stores and stuff and and like
find little like half used dandelion uh crayons and stuff
and then it was like a discontinued color and eventually
they brought back the color because she loved it so much oh
hey hey you yeah am i helping out okay I'd be as good as
dead.
That's true.
Hang on.
Are you suggesting I'm not pulling my way here?
Where did you get that from?
You're doing great.
And you're really, really useful.
Useful?
It gets kind of bumpy riding on your back, though.
It's hard to hold on sometimes.
Where did it, he's so, are you insecure, Hugh?
Why did you interpret it in that way, huh?
Could have really messed yourself up back there.
Do you not feel pain or something?
feel it like humans do but my system will assign it a
numerical value i was designed to experience human feelings
and sensations like you do wow well it don't seem like it
falling from a place like that you should know better you
gotta be more careful oh with the cat i want to see you get
hurt got it got it you gotta be careful too okay no problem
i'm gonna go change the jazz if you've got
I like the jazz, but it's so loud for some reason.
We'll do.
We'll do lo-fi.
We'll be here.
If you need us.
The Terminator said the same thing.
Are you implying that Diana will turn into the Terminator?
I did upgrade everything that I wanted to at the moment, so
let's head back and do the red room.
Oh, dude.
Uh, equip mods.
Oh, obtain the following.
Oh, that's right.
The close quarters and the extended breach.
Right now we have increased max HP.
I think I might keep that though.
Oh, and also the skirmisher.
We maybe get rid of this one and do the close quarters since
I've been using the shoddy a lot.
Okay.
Get in the tram!
Oh, whoops.
Try the tram to...
It was this one, right?
The entrance?
Read Earth Memory.
Yeah, yeah, right here, right here.
Wait, what the heck?
I got nothing here!
And here!
I'm the worst.
Wait.
How did I not find anything?
Maybe they're...
Just tell me that they're behind stuff that I can't unlock
yet.
Most encounters have been close range so far.
You're so right, right?
You can't for now.
Okay.
Something's in an upgrade floor.
All right.
Good.
I don't feel so bad anymore.
Also, I feel like I should...
Gamers don't look up.
I'm looking up.
All right, let's go try this.
Bad boy.
I'm scared!
Oh!
I don't even get a choice of like...
What if you...
What if I say no?
What if I say never mind?
I don't want to do it anymore.
Okay.
Good luck?
Is it that bad?
I'll get the riot blaster out.
There's the guy.
Nah, well, thank you so much, brother.
Thank you, thank you!
this net.
Would that be better than the riot blaster?
Yeah, Diana's ult is ready.
Oh, wait.
Wait!
Holy cow!
He almost came at me for real.
What do you drop?
Shockwave gun.
Um.
I have to get these guys now, probably.
Okay.
Oh wait.
Oh shoot, I'm too far.
Or, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Yeah, oh, uh, why did I do that?
Okay, oh there's more.
Oh gosh.
Oh, oops.
Ah!
It's okay, we'll get another shot.
I should have known it was easier.
Or, ah.
Yeah!
Oh, shoot.
They're not down yet.
Here it comes.
Look out.
Okay.
Jump, Q.
I'm running.
I'm jumping.
I'm grabbing that.
Who's what?
Coming.
Oh, no!
Wow!
Uh...
Get him, get him?
Also...
Oh, oh shoot!
Uh...
Never mind.
Oh shoot!
That was close.
And die!
Joy!
They need to be hacked again.
That's okay.
Jump Q!
I need to get this guy, though.
He's annoying me.
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch.
Oh no!
He had the...
He had the purple.
It's okay.
We'll just get him, though.
Oh!
Ouch!
Uh-oh.
Ouch, ouch.
I didn't realize he was about to step.
L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L-L.
Oh, run, run.
What is this?
Oh, the multi-head.
I'll take more of those.
Yes.
Thank you.
Ah, she's so supportive.
Oh.
Yeah, we'll change it.
Multi-hack.
Yippee!
I did have my ult, but I don't think I needed it.
I did almost die.
I was hoping we find it.
Me too.
Nice.
Now we go back.
There we go.
Only one heal used.
Yeah!
We had two heals left.
We'll go back and then we'll go to the other area that we
were.
All right.
But I feel...
I mean, look, now I can even get the fast move, so let's do
it.
Wait, what was the other thing?
Oh, the node slot.
Maybe the fast moves will be good for now.
Did you say node slot?
Could save it if there's something else you want.
Well, at the moment, there's nothing else that requires it.
So I feel like spending it is okay.
I think I'll get the dodge.
The fast moves.
I think it's good to get skills.
And it's only one thing, so honestly it's like not so bad.
Do I...
Yippee!
I have no more coins though.
Overclocked weaponry.
The overclocked weaponry mod will be uploaded.
Chargeable weapons charge 30% faster.
Self-defense response.
Reduces damage received by 20% when your HP is below 50.
Hugh outfit.
Just the outfit.
Alright.
You're leaving so soon?
Have a pleasant journey.
Thank you.
Alrighty.
Let's head out.
I think everything is still okay.
But now I'm like...
There was the...
I guess I...
I'm not getting any REMs.
For my shelter.
Weigh!
I want more toys!
I want more toys.
Where?
Alright, we're going this way.
Wait a second.
Are they down here?
They're not down here.
The big babies, they're not down here, are they?
Are they not down here yet?
Maybe they're alright.
It's scary jumping from here.
Let's jump from here instead.
Oh,
thank goodness there's no fall damage though, right?
The big babies, I don't want them to see me.
No!
Charge piercer.
Powerful attack unit that fires...
Oh no, armor piercing rounds.
When charged, his power and pierce effects dramatically
increase.
Unaffected by range, it excels at striking from afar.
Oh, geez.
it did okay
probably should try it probably should try it I don't like
that I have to choose though between my hello open up I have
to choose between my shoddy and this there's the trash for
anybody who was saying that this is not New York Here's all
the garbage.
Now where are the rats?
Oh, I thought I saw the baby.
Eww, I hate drones!
What's out for its targeting sensor?
Can I get... I can't hack it from here.
Oh.
And brown!
Ugh.
As long as it's only drones, it's not so bad, I guess.
I got him.
Be careful.
Oh, wait.
I don't want to waste it on this guy.
There we go.
The baby!
Look!
The big old piece of junk again.
Holy.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I didn't get the baby.
Holy.
Oh my god.
Ew, what's it doing?
Ew.
Correct.
Uh, wait.
Oops, wrong thing.
How you like this?
Actually can't quite tell.
Ew.
What's coming out of its face?
Are they blocking your hack?
Oh,
they are.
Uh, I have to shoot them.
Wait, can I?
Oh, probably can't go get the shotgun.
Oh, my God.
Excuse me, turn around.
Turn around, big baby.
Oh.
My aim.
Hoi!
He's so stupid.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
We still got it.
Oh, gosh.
It's so creepy.
Get him in the booty!
Get him in the...
Oh, there we go.
Oh, I saw the purple.
I should have done it.
We got the baby.
We blew up the baby.
Nice.
What's this?
Oh.
Things I could have grabbed.
Things that maybe would have made the fight a little bit
easier.
I don't even need the repair kit.
Bad time to mention there are still two more babies.
I remember.
I remember that there are still two more.
I remember unfortunately, but there are two more babies.
I didn't want there to be any more babies.
I... Whoa, look at the car!
What?
Oh my gosh.
Look out for its targeting something.
Yeah, stupid.
Oh, whoops.
I didn't mean to do that.
I didn't mean to not...
That's okay though.
What have we got?
We got a relay!
Amplifier increases...
Hacking range by 30%!
Wait, that's so good!
That wolf lets me hack from farther away!
Yeah, we want that.
Nice.
More range, more range.
Give it to me.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Oh, wow!
It's really starting to look like a regular city.
With the trees and stuff.
And the crosswalk.
One way.
There's two little beacons right there.
I can see a beacon over there on that tree.
I can see three whole beacons!
Diana, it's huge.
It's huge.
I could see three whole beacons.
So if I fall...
I bet there's...
I bet you there's a baby down there, though.
I see I think that will unleash some some guys I
can look inside that apartment that's a little weird get
that bacon oh there's a guy down there too why don't they
like us what
was it oh what do you mean move what is this thing actually
What are you?
I keep missing the purple node.
It's just a little guy.
He didn't really do much.
He just kind of stared at me.
Oh, I think he's gonna...
Oh, never mind.
Actually, he...
Missile!
Ah!
Oh my gosh, cool!
Nice.
Hmm?
was that a bacon oh it's nice return to sender all right
that's three all right we're already halfway there why is
that four we're halfway there whoa one over there what
where's the other one that door the communications tower is
like how are we even supposed to get in there Living not a
prayer.
There was another one right over there.
Was there not?
Hmm.
Mysterious.
Wait.
What's down here, though?
I wish I could cheese this.
Oh, there's two!
They're in the corner.
Oh, no.
They're stupid.
I'd try the front door.
Oh, wait.
There's three of them.
There's one that's the guard.
and then the two that are dumb.
It's the three stooges.
What are they doing?
Dummy dumps.
It's the thing!
And two more hot dogs!
Upgrade.
Wow, that was pretty far there's the other one i knew it was
around oh like the beam kind of blended in
did you hear that it was a clock oh getting close to snipe
time nice humans really need to eat more than once a day i
wish your energy efficiency doesn't seem good sure that's
fair but sharing a meal is that is a Huge apple.
Why is the apple so big?
So, at dinner with my new family, just having someone that
had listened was magical.
It was all kid stuff, but they were always there.
Talking with someone who just accepts you for you is a kind
of nourishment, but for your soul.
You can get nutrients from talking?
Something like that.
Why do they have so many apples?
We don't have baskets and baskets full of apples.
Honestly, I'm here for it.
What is this?
Wait, we can get...
Tuna?
Tuna.
Where?
There's another beacon.
I bet Edis is down there too.
Tuna.
Where?
I think he's down.
Yalbs!
That's my birthday, but I wanted a gift to you because
you're such a gift to us.
I would...
Thank you for being awesome, Mito.
Yalbs, happy birthday!
What the heck?
Thank you so much!
Thank you for the super duper generous gift.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
You should know, you should gift yourself, though.
What the heck?
Thank you!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday, y'all.
Let's see if we can see Tuna from over here.
Tuna!
Oh, wow.
I think we're gonna get ambushed here, you guys.
Surely.
Over this way.
I see him.
Bingo!
Surely all of these won't open up and uh and ambush us here
right in front of the um
right in front of the beacon yeah don't call me Shirley you
can call me Shirley I think I'm right
this guy right here.
I w- okay, wait.
I wonder if I- because there's like a wall, see like the- I
can't remember if I can pass through that or not.
Oh, it causes the alarm.
If I pass through.
Isn't that- yeah, it sets off the alarm.
If I were to like get the beacon, hmm.
But then also, I want that.
I think if I get that, I would have to fall down to around
to come all the way back up here.
You know?
I think so.
It's shiny.
You got ult and multi-hacking, so you good.
So much rue.
This one is tough.
Prepare yourself.
Maybe I grab this guy and then we fall and do everything
down there and then come back up here for this beacon.
Uh-oh.
I thought I landed.
I thought I...
I thought
I...
The barrier.
And the REM.
Wait, where do you see the REM?
Oh yeah, yeah, that's it.
It's right there, yeah.
Just kidding.
You're right.
Tuna.
There's something shiny down there.
I can't tell if it's something I...
Oh, I think it's just a sign.
Okay, just kidding.
Okay.
Let's grab.
Oh, slide!
There's a reason this humble playground fixture is always a
hit.
It may be simple, but that doesn't make it any less fun.
It also serves as a great secret hideout.
Nice.
I wonder what that is.
Oh, you're gonna love it.
It's like the coolest thing ever.
What is this?
Oh.
Grab a bot.
Let's get some good stuff.
Don't let it get away!
Wait!
Wait, wait, what do you mean don't let it get away?
Huh?
Stop scaring around.
Here it comes.
Look out.
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
Shoot!
Wait, I totally messed that up.
Oh, shit.
Let's do this.
Oh.
Oh my god, no way there's more.
Wait, why are there so many?
Wait, no!
I was supposed to get this special!
Get him in the butt!
Oh.
I was supposed to get him in the butt.
I mean...
No!
Maybe I switched to this for...
the next thing too might be better maybe not quite sure I
feel like it's very close range everything so say that again
I said what I said and I meant it I don't think I got that
one guy though that kept dropping these I think I let him
get away too bad we'll use my ult on the next area though
and then we have this as Well, this is fine to drop down
here for.
Watch the next battle be long range.
No, it won't.
Long range.
Increases attack power by 10% when the enemy is over.
Well, we have the close range one at the moment.
I wonder what weapons that would work with.
Can we go in here?
Oh, oops.
Got it.
That was close.
But I don't need to, I think this is after.
Maybe?
I'm actually not quite sure.
Multi-hack!
For now!
Wait...
What is this one?
Well, stasis net.
Look, I can see inside these people's homes.
I think that's everything here.
Was it a shortcut?
You think so?
I can't remember...
Oh, here's the map.
No...
I don't know where this goes.
Let's check it out.
It is a shortcut!
Oh, it's this door!
Oh!
It was a shortcut!
The one that didn't open earlier.
Yeah!
It's gonna say shortcut to where?
Dang, we have to go, like, all the way back around.
It's okay, though.
Beep, beep, beep.
Nice.
Oh, let's grab this, too.
We need these.
All right.
Good little detour.
I guess I probably should have gone there.
first but that's okay that's a okay all right let's do this
fight do the shock wave gun and pray and our ult our ult
there we go i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry oh shoot
oh Targeting this.
Okay.
Just...
Wait, can I...
Ah!
Ouch!
Wait, get me down from there, please?
Please?
Oh, it's that guy!
Get ready!
Leave the shooting to me!
Reload, reload, reload, reload.
Reload.
Right back at you!
Oh, I don't think it actually hit him.
That sucks.
Step off.
Oh, wait.
I want to do my RT!
Yeah!
So far, so good.
But I know it's not over.
Deploying reinforcements.
Yeah!
It's a baby!
Oh shoot, it's a baby.
Holy shit!
Oh my god.
Yeah!
Stupid baby.
Uh, uh.
I'm scared of it though.
I'm scared of this thing.
Oops.
I owe you.
Uh.
What's it doing?
You know what?
Alt!
Alt it, yeah.
Wow!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, that's the first time we saw that happen.
That's crazy.
Oh, shoot.
Wait!
Be careful.
Oh my gosh.
Please don't get me.
Oh.
shoot.
Oh my god, there's so much going on over here.
Wait, this was a bad area.
Is it coming to?
Baby?
Yeah!
Scary area, scary area!
Oh my gosh.
Holy cow.
Okay, okay.
Finish the baby.
I'm trying.
Holy cow.
Oh, oh, shoot.
I need to shoot his face.
I'm trying to like get all the other things first because
there's just so much around there's so much around I wish I
could get other guides that are right here oh my god oh I
tried to leave but
nice dodges thank you
she's knocking over everything missile spotted missile
spotted oops well it's fine I wish I could get his face.
Oh my god.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
It's okay, I'll heal after this.
Just in case.
Oh, shoot.
He's...
Healing.
Let's go over to him and RT.
Yeah!
Uh.
Oh, that was crazy looking.
No!
Wait, maybe...
Wait, this is crazy!
Yeah!
Okay, just one guy left.
Oh, oops.
I didn't mean to do that.
That's funny.
Nice finisher.
Yippee!
The baby has been neutralized.
Oh.
Let's change back to the shockwave then.
I should have been picking up more weapons.
Grab my loot from up here as well.
We'll take you as well.
That was intense.
Woof.
Very smooth first try.
Thank you.
you i really like this game this game is like i don't want
to say it's easy to play but like it just feels good to play
you know what i mean i can't yeah it's either one or the
other like you can't have both at the moment oops i'm stupid
got it yeah very satisfying gameplay yeah yeah yeah two more
to go it flows very well we can We can do this, Hugh.
We can do this!
Yeah.
What we got going on here?
Breaking news from Delphi.
Delphi Corporation, which has experienced rapid growth
through lunar development, today announced a strategic
partnership between its CEO, David Aldrin, President
Svetlana Tereshkova.
You obliterated that infant.
Great job.
That's why you're the boss.
Yeah.
I've seen many streamers die on that fight.
He just got a dodge.
The director of this game worked on MGS Rising.
That's right!
The director of this game was the character designer for MGS
Rising.
Do you guys...
Do you guys see it?
I...
Like...
I get it.
Just dodge forehead.
It tracks.
And Dr. Neal Higgins, a leading expert in quantum
nanotechnology.
Industry observers are eagerly awaiting the results of this
collaboration, particularly the potential of this miracle
material, Luna filament, when combined with Delphi's
unparalleled Luna developmental capabilities.
Dr. Neal Higgins.
That name rings a bell.
It does?
so what's next after work finishes on new york well i've
been thinking maybe something with a bit more history
history how about something japanese isn't that where you're
from what about something in the kigumi style like you'd see
with the temples in nara they're made entirely from wood but
can supposedly stand over a thousand years nothing but wood
just thinking of Wow.
You'd need wooden samples at least a hundred years old for
something that's wrong.
Oh.
A worthy challenge.
But with Luna Filament, everything is possible.
Everything.
At this point, it probably does really feel like a miracle.
A miracle material, you know?
Yippee!
Yeah, lucky find.
Can't forget you.
I think I do want to go back and heal.
What's so nice about these, like, the placement of these,
uh, these, like, return ladders is that they're always in a
spot where it's just like, oh, you know, you could go back
and you'd have to face the enemies, but it's also in a spot
where it's like, oh, you go back and you don't have to deal
with any, any guys.
We got our slide!
Tell me when it's go time, okay?
It's go time.
For the slide.
Where's my slide?
Here's your slide.
Getting nutrients from talking?
That's so weird.
I lose nutrients from talking because I'm an introvert and I
have a very low social battery.
Slide!
Whoa, it's huge!
I got a cabin coin.
What do you do with this?
Should I climb up it?
This slide's too small for you.
I wanted to slide down together.
No, it's okay.
Wee!
It's...
Oh, she's so strong.
She's literally pushing me out of the way.
She's like...
She became a super saiyan for the slide.
Zoom!
I want more REMs, Hugh.
Green knows no bounds.
I want more REMs.
The wind feels so nice when I'm sliding.
I wish I could go faster.
i could use your thrusters sometime nope great idea oh these
things aren't toys jeez i was only joking i know that i'm
not so sure about that after your track record with cats
don't make her look sad you have you ever lived in new york
nope never oh really nice but you know so much about it
though honestly you can't escape the big apple it's a movies
tv heck it's everywhere that's true it's even on the damn
moon apparently pretty solid job making look like the real
thing though i'm excited to go to the other areas then if
they made this one new york if what other areas look like
diana if you ever need anything let me know need okay i saw
cool yeah oh there it is she still likes after everything
she still likes her coloring the most so much fun that I
kind of made a mess.
Let's see.
Let's get some stamps, baby.
Um, let's do the mysterious one.
I'm curious.
Oh, we got another red gate key!
Oh, I guess they give that to you in case you don't...
If you...
We are honored to provide one of our greatest goods.
Okay.
Uh...
Hmm.
We'll do the bot data last so we can get the other nice
stuff first.
But we do need the triple bingo.
The unit printer will generate the freeze hacking node.
This node can temporarily stun a target.
Oh.
Wait, that's kind of nice too, though.
We hope you enjoy your purchase.
Thank you.
No.
Oh, oops.
Wait.
I went too fast.
The charge piercer.
Oh, and the charge speed goes up too.
Rate of fire, ammo capacity.
Let's upgrade these three for now.
Let's just get them to level two.
Because it's only 100 each.
Or wait, actually, Oh, wait, I'm unlocking them.
I'm a silly goose.
But unlocking them is important, too, anyway, so.
There we go.
And Diana had the question mark.
It's an interaction prompt.
Is it?
Getting nutrients from talking.
That's so weird.
She's doing it again, though.
That's so weird as she walks away.
What's she gonna do now?
She's gonna stay on there.
She's gonna...
Look at that, Q!
She's gonna go over here.
And we can upgrade some more!
I could do more damage.
Or we could do more hacking damage!
Heat gauge build up 20.
Upgrade the Diana.
Okay.
Wait.
I'm like either my...
Diana's a powerful gun.
That's true.
Let's do it.
Yeah!
Girl-shaped gun.
My favorite.
Getting nutrients from talking.
She's always got this extra exclamation point around.
Um...
Oh wait, they're talking.
She's just running all around.
Um...
What else do we want to upgrade?
Oh, I can get the node slot!
I think that would be pretty good.
And, um...
Hmm.
We could get another mod slot.
Mods are good.
Hacking gauge.
Gain build up from completed hacks.
We'll do that too.
The nerd slot.
Did you just say nerd?
Someone noticed that Diana moves like the cats for a monster
hunter as if they have the same mocap actors.
I mean, they might, honestly.
Oh, repair up, you're so right.
Repair up is good.
Yes, yes.
We can do the overdrive next time.
Maybe save up for more thrusters, too.
But I feel like...
We have a good amount of stuff right now.
Yeah, like the Palico.
Where is she?
Anyway, oh.
Let's keep going.
Uh...
Tactical.
Riot Blaster.
Stasis Net.
Shotgun.
We will do the...
We will do the shotgun, though.
Custom made.
It's the exact same, but it's the DS version.
Is this...
This must be the DLC, probably.
Maybe it's a skin.
It's a skin from the DLC, I think.
Okay, that's what I thought.
It matches, though.
We still have one slot.
This defense unit.
And we got an extra node so we can add...
Wait.
Oh, I didn't...
Let's go unlock it.
Okay.
Because I think it's silly to not have Otherwise, yeah,
we'll unlock it.
There we go.
Because now I'll be able to carry both, I think.
It didn't seem like I could before.
Maybe I was wrong.
Maybe I'm wrong.
Oh!
Obtain the following mods.
Increase hacking range by...
Oh, that, that, that!
That!
Increase that!
We want that!
Equip?
Oh, not equip mods.
out.
Hacking notes.
Is that.
There we go.
Okay.
Walk and loaded.
Yeah.
I think we're good now.
Office space.
I missed one safe box.
I wonder where.
I wonder if there was a...
I wonder if there was a wall, like one of the walls that was
fake.
time to take your robo daughter to work day yippee yeah
secret wall
oh I just realized I didn't have to take the tram but that's
okay we could have just climbed the stairs again but that's
fine it was where the REM was above it no kidding okay
that's fine
so how What have we gotten rid of all the babies?
What's going on?
Oh, if I jump down.
No, there's more babies!
Go away!
Go away, baby!
So eventually we learn how to get rid of these.
I see, I figured we would have to.
So there's a lot of places that we haven't been able to go
to of it huh i really don't feel like jumping after that so
we're just gonna keep we're just gonna keep going up or is
this gonna secret wall no ah ah oh how safe safe just
one more when they will find an option to one more to go all
right it's all downhill from here that's what I say I said
it's all downhill from here and I was told that that means a
bad thing
oh what did I just do oh
where was this drop down to
he is you after all.
Ew, there's two of them.
Hold on to your heini.
My what?
Something out of an amusement park here.
Where?
I'll tell you later.
What does, where does that go to though, if I drop from
here?
I'm curious.
Hold on to your heini.
Your heinihole.
Oh!
At least to where I just was.
Okay, okay.
Because I recognize that.
Okay.
That's fine.
For how massive we are, our landings are so soft.
You know?
Oh, okay.
Just like that.
Cool.
Don't make it weird.
That's literally what my dad would tell me all the time.
So, I don't know.
It's not me making it weird.
Oh, that's a forklift.
Uh-huh.
See, we need to be able to get in here.
I wonder what would happen if we turn this on.
Don't know.
Oh, there's a guy in there!
They really are like weirdo zombies.
Like the way they kind of stand.
Reminds me of Sam Jackson's character in Jurassic Park.
Who?
Sam Jackson.
Handling the limb recycler.
When disposing of bots in the limb recycler, strictly follow
these steps below.
Place the target object in the irradiation zone.
Verify that the object is completely inside the irradiation
zone, then activate the recycler.
Hold on to your butts!
Warning, standing within the irradiation zone during
recycler activation will result in fatal lacerations.
So bored out of my mind.
I wanted a job that actually mattered.
So I volunteered to help out managing the recycling unit.
But even here, the bots do it all.
Leaving me with nothing to keep my hands or mind busy.
Maybe that's why everybody wants to leave.
Because the robots are doing everything.
Routine tasks, heavy lifting, precision work.
Everything is handled better than I ever could.
All I do is press the disposal button from time to time.
Emptiness gnaws at me.
Avoid, I cannot escape.
Sometimes I wonder.
Were the bots created not to serve us but to take away any
sense of purpose we might have had?
Ooh.
So is it off now?
Can I walk through?
I'm guessing so?
New.
What is it?
Decoy generator?
A defense unit that creates a lifelike hologram decoy.
Oh, is this part of the defense?
Maybe?
Are you trying to tell us something game dev?
I know, how topical.
And it's funny because this game, what, hasn't it been like
six years in the making?
Oh yeah, select weapon down.
Draw enemy attention for a short time when deployed.
The decoy itself does not deal damage.
Okay.
I want to see what it looks like.
Oh, that's me!
What a dummy.
What?
Oh my god, they're so stupid.
Use that to full bots 100% of the time.
Maybe.
Oh, what's going on in there?
Oh, that scared me.
Full bots 100% of the time, you said.
100% asterisk, yeah.
I'm guessing I don't want to go in there, right?
Right?
I'm scared.
What if I get fatal lacerations?
60% of the time, it works every time.
You got this, Minto?
Is this a scary part?
Fatal lacerations?
Oh.
Maybe not.
Maybe I can wait.
Oh,
another one!
Holy cow!
She took out!
I did it.
Massive damage.
Too bad that we, uh, missed that guy, but that's fine.
I feel like that was supposed to happen.
It was pretty close though with the guy over here.
Almost didn't get him.
The guy on the left.
But we did.
We're all good.
Let's keep going.
Decoy Octopus.
On standby.
Binto is a gamer?
What do you mean?
Oh, I got a data shard.
Decoy.
No, it won't multi.
I'm confused.
Okay, yeah.
I'm blocking it, but...
Here, I'll show you guys.
You can see I have the 3D code to hacker.
Multi-hacker.
So it's just below me.
Eject.
Oh, secret wall!
There.
Oh, God.
We found one!
Mama.
It was actually so obvious.
Which is kind of funny.
Perfect limitations.
Oh, imitations.
They finally granted me level at 5 access.
At last, I can dig into the read Earth memory data that's
still in development.
Technically, I'm not supposed to peek without an approved
research request.
But I just couldn't wait.
I printed out as much as I could.
If my boss ever founds out, I'll never hear the end of it.
So I've tucked in the evidence behind my usual wall.
and if they do catch me well i'll own up and apologize
curiosity has its price yeah you do the thing and then you
beg for forgiveness that always works it turns out rems
don't simply mimic materials they're perfect imitations the
accuracy of paintings and art pieces i printed is incredible
you can't even tell them apart at a glance they really are
amazing little things still even though scanning technology
has approved improved you still need supplementary data to
precisely replicate the internal structures.
The question is, how is Delphi acquiring this information?
Well, I'm sure I'll find out soon enough.
Sharon.
Very interesting.
End of the road?
Oh.
Uh...
Well, we get an REM.
A century old...
It's a century old TV designed for transmitting sound and
images also serves as a stylish decor piece.
Our only way out is down.
I thought it was about to play the Among Us.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Do-do-do.
I have a feeling this would happen.
Oh shoot!
a baby oh my god holy cow wait how you like this
dummy baby oh my god how did i miss
stupid baby stupid baby
no no no
i'm fine i got this thing in between me
He's charging!
Did I hit me?
Yippee!
The wall got wrecked so bad, but no, I know.
That's exactly what I wanted to do.
Let's go kill him.
Take this!
Yay!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Easy.
what are these doing which I can't remember what these ones
do obviously I know the multi-hack maybe it shocked oh nice
yes I would like that is there anything here besides this
where are all these cars here for just lower defense oh okay
okay I'll start I'll try to remember to use it more than oh
Tuna!
Can I hit you?
Bottom.
Ah, three for three!
Tuna!
Oh!
I'm a gamer!
Yeah!
Oh, wait, I think I'm supposed to go this way.
Never mind.
Yeah, I thought I was doing something real special and fun.
Happy birthday, Thomas!
Two Thomas from Cradle Mail Forwarding Service!
I don't know why, but that cabin was so hard to find for me.
Really?
Happy second birthday on the moon, my love.
Did you make another one of those fake cakes with the food
replicator like last year?
wait until next year when we can finally celebrate your
birthday together only about six more months until you're
back in each until we're back in each other's arms i'm so
proud of you honey i love you p.s coco says she can't wait
to see you meow your beautiful wife kristen
no thomas no thomas thomas you better be alive somewhere you
have to go back to your beautiful
I hope they're not.
I hope he's alive.
No!
Pet Bot Lottery Application.
After long suspension, we're reopening the lottery
application for pet type animal bots.
These round features...
This round features three adorable models.
Cats, canaries, and rats.
Where's the lizards?
I want a lizard.
and for this round only you can customize iris and fur
colors perfect for recreating your favorite earth pet apply
now to claim yours please note size coat density and other
details cannot be specified all units must be returned to
the cradle before earth departure thank you for your
understanding one always hired party huh why do humans
celebrate getting older life's worth celebrating every new
year is another gift Look at all these places we can't go!
Oh, there's three of them.
Four of them.
Yoiks.
Deco- I think we decoy gun them and then decoy gun them into
the thing.
and then activate it.
Can I even do that, though?
Ah, this is kind of tricky.
Decoy into the yellow zone.
Yeah, I, uh...
But it's kind of...
Will they notice me?
You see the red button?
Yeah.
Oh, I can hack it from here, though.
That's kind of awesome.
Good to know.
I wish I could...
Oh, wait.
Maybe here?
No, no, no, what are you doing?
What are you doing?
Is that far enough?
I can't tell.
Here we go.
Oh, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop.
Oh, they didn't notice me at all.
Uh...
How long does that stay up for?
Notice him, not me!
Notice him!
Notice!
That's okay.
We just have one now.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
And he's still stupid, so it's okay.
Notice him!
Not me!
You can copy yourself with that.
Well, it's a good thing.
They gave me two.
But, what's up here then?
Because there's a two-way to go.
Could this have all been a...
Oh, no.
It's just more stuff.
Just a chest.
Cabin coin!
Alright, yeah, they are fun to collect, aren't they?
I do want to go...
Well, I don't want to go back.
Oh, shoot.
I should have gone back before destroying these guys, huh?
Because we have to give her her TV.
That's fine.
We'll just keep going.
What's my health looking like?
Oh, I'm full health.
Oh,
it's scary.
Data shard.
There's one up there, too.
Oh, that was close.
Holy moly.
That was really close.
I'm being greedy.
It's literally right here.
I could turn it off literally immediately I'm making things
so much harder on myself
Always go for greed Yes we can
No No Just climb Just climb over it What's wrong?
What is this?
Hold
on Do I go down here?
Maybe Maybe More money?
These blue rocks gotta be story important.
Bought disposal costs.
The management system just threw up a warning.
Your limb recycler usage is off the charts.
Think about it.
One tiny scrap or three giant chunks.
Power cost is the same.
Is using it on high cost items whenever possible really that
hard for you to grasp?
Keep your head in the game, Kevin.
Or the AI might decide you're the next one.
thing to recycle okay Nigel geez sheesh oh no our taxi got
all messed up there's more stuff back there too you think I
can oh no this is a wall I got a thing hey let me see one
zero zero one zero one one one one zero one zero one zero
one Eat it?
Diana?
Don't...
Okay.
It's Appy Juice.
I think I see how it works.
I should be able to break this down.
Wait, no kidding?
Wait, really?
Already?
I'm gonna try something.
That's my girl.
Yes!
He also tosses it.
That was great.
She's so cute.
Glad to hear it.
Yippee!
Yay, we can get rid of the things now.
High five!
Do you think it tastes like a Switch cartridge?
That's exactly what I was thinking it tasted like.
So what's the high five?
Erase filament masses scattered throughout the cradle!
Now I have a question for this though.
If we get rid of these, I guess it doesn't really matter.
But for the sake of me knowing where I've been before and
all, is this like the enemies where it grows back?
after we get rid of it.
Duncorn, quick, look at the monitor.
They do not come back, okay, cool.
Look at the size of that boat.
It's attacking humans.
Why, where is Edith?
Why is it they're doing anything?
Edith is the one that ordered the attack.
No, that can't be.
It's trying to get in.
It's almost there.
Quick, we're gonna get out of here.
What happened to these people?
You know anything?
I haven't seen anyone besides you since leaving the vault.
I can't believe we haven't found any survivors.
On a good sign.
Yeah.
But there's no plethora in bodies or anything.
I don't imagine they cleaned it up, right?
This spot's all cool.
Nice.
And you get cash for it, too.
Awesome.
Wait, let's go back and clear the other areas then.
Maybe the bodies got recycled.
Ooh, that's a dark thought, isn't it?
Left every other mess, but clean the bodies.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
It's strange, right?
Oh, what's down there?
Wait a second.
Yeah, everybody escaped and survived.
So true.
Was this a shortcut outside?
Okay.
Where are we?
Wait, that means the babies are around.
Right?
There's a baby!
Okay, run away.
Let's go see what was in here.
Wait, is this a door?
Nope.
What's down here?
Area 3.
The evil forklift that is red.
Sector 6.
I think we have to come back here right I think so once we
have higher access interesting okay I'll try and note that
but I probably will forget oh wait but This is Sector 6.
Never mind.
I don't know anymore.
It's a shortcut door, if I remember correctly.
Ah, okay.
Very cool.
That was where we fought the baby.
This is the only door to go.
Big baby.
And there's androids too.
Oh wait, but this is a...
This is a recycler.
Where is the button?
I think it's...
Why is it outside?
Hi, I'm into Hope You're Well.
I'm here at Duke University.
We're an appointment tomorrow.
We'll discuss more options.
Wish me luck.
Good luck, Brandon!
Good luck!
I hope everything works out.
Get your kicks and sector six.
You can only drive the evil forklift if you are not
certified.
Or if you're evil certified.
Well, I don't like this at all.
I have to leave and then...
Wait!
How am I supposed to...
I guess I have to...
Wait.
Oh gosh, there's so many of them.
Okay, hold on.
There's the beacon right there.
There's two...
Maybe three guys in there.
Yeah, there's three guys at least in there.
and then there's oh there's several guys here oh my gosh
there's so many guys here i'm evil uncertified evil
certified i like it can you distract them i can i can't
i can't see me from the door because otherwise look it look
look there's nowhere to stand that i won't be vaporized and
suffer lacerations i keep calling that thing the baby but i
it's looking a little less baby like to me it's like it's
like it's like uh you know before they made the minecraft
mobs like um actually like babyheaded and everything they
were like just shrunken villagers and stuff it's a baby.
Oh, you're so right.
You're so right.
The big head and the tantrum movements make it baby-like.
That's true.
It doesn't actually hurt that much.
It said fatal.
What if I jump?
Let's try.
This seems really bad.
Oh, wait.
I can stand right here.
Oh.
To be fair, fatal doesn't mean it hurts.
Yeah, it just means death.
I'm scared of this part.
Alright, here we go.
I haven't died yet in the game, so I'm not quite sure what
will happen if I die.
Oh.
Uh.
Oh,
shoot.
Oh, no, I already used it.
Uh-oh.
I think I messed up.
Stop skittering around.
Jump, cute.
Ah!
Get fucked.
I keep saying he's...
I keep thinking he's saying get fucked.
Am I the only one that hears that?
Oh, shoot.
Ouch.
I didn't mean to.
I keep hearing it.
Take this.
He's saying step off, but I keep hearing something else.
A little unsavory.
The baby.
Ah!
Look, distract!
Holy cow.
Uh, oh, uh, sorry.
I got a little lost in the sauce for a second.
Yay!
Now it's my turn.
Oops.
We're reloading?
Can the net work?
Oh, it does.
Nice.
Get ready.
Oh, oops.
Oh, shoot now!
Oh!
Oh, that hurt.
Oh shoot, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch!
Oh gosh, I'm cornered!
Oh, please get up, please get up, Hugh!
Oh, gosh, he doesn't stay open for a long time, does he?
I keep getting the multiple, but it's fine, it's fine.
Yay!
Oh, I messed it up, I should have used- I forgot that it was
a one-time use!
I forgot.
Oh, I also had another gun here.
But I had my stasis.
No, it's fine.
Binto gaming.
I forgot it was one time use.
And I used it on all the robots.
Oh, there's another gun here too.
Yeah, the email was a hint to save it for the big target.
I know.
I messed it up.
But it's fine.
We did it anyway.
It's whatever.
Clutch some parts of that fight.
Thanks!
We did it!
Yeah!
You're doing great, Diana.
Aww.
What about me?
Oh, we're here!
You're doing great, Hugh.
So I...
What we can do is we'll head back and then we can go through
there.
And that's our shortcut.
What about me?
Yeah, am I doing great?
Second red zone.
Wait, I didn't see it where the second one was.
Did I miss it?
Second red zone.
Want to check if we can upgrade anything?
Yeah, also, I have a present.
You said later, right?
Is now a good time?
CRT.
I kind of want to go to the old areas now and, like, see,
you know?
series complete replicating related objects whoa oh my gosh
it's a whole bedroom we've collected the entire
gemini girls have available on streaming services that's so
funny as a crt but they're streaming there's always
something on earth things are fun is fun but it's also kind
of boring huh i thought you liked tv i do but when i'm
watching playroom not bedroom oh i don't know and was there
is there a difference my playroom was my bedroom i wasted a
bunch of time doesn't help that the show lineup here is so
thin at least on earth waiting for the next week's episode
is something to look forward to i don't want to wait i know
How come you always look like you're having such a good
time?
She is having a good time.
I'm just happy to be here.
Me too.
People, when people are just like, why does Mint laugh so
much?
I don't know.
I just think everything's so funny.
Hey, don't you get tired of hanging around the shelter?
Are you bored, Hugh?
If so, let's pretend we're cats.
I'll be a cute striped one, and you'll be a big white
furball.
Maybe next time, github.
else i gotta do it's like the most oh yeah that thing it's
like the most like child thing it's so funny drawing was so
much fun not missing any colors nope they're all there glad
to hear it crayons tend to run off and the ones you use the
most they're gone before the crowd crayons can run yeah
gotta put them away right that's true they do roll She was
so excited about that information.
I want to watch Gemini girls.
What the heck is wrong with her hands?
What is wrong with her hands?
Why are her hands like that?
Same.
Minto giggles.
Heal my soul.
Please keep laughing.
Laugh is cute.
Edis got the hands wrong.
It's so strange.
Blocks.
That's us.
That's the bad robots.
I guess this would be a playroom more than a...
Wow, imagine being so fancy.
You could have a whole room for playing in.
That's not your bedroom.
Fancy.
Dinosaur.
Fancy, look at that cat.
It's so good.
I wonder what is in that picture frame.
A fish?
Maybe?
Lion.
Oh, it is a fish.
I see it in this one.
Yeah, it's a fish.
Nice.
It's a fish.
Wait!
You said later.
What's an amusement park?
I can tell you.
This is my special interest.
They have this thing with a cart.
You ride up real high, then come crashing back down.
And this other thing, you ride up in the air, and they spin
you around in circles.
Mm-hmm.
That doesn't sound fun.
I don't know.
Kids usually go wild for them.
Kids sound kind of weird.
Kids are weird.
jack well a quick scan shows all my systems are operating
okay so i guess you're doing okay cool we got all the
dialogue look at all of our guys all dapper cool dapper
fancy fancy drugged up what she oh she's on the slide all
the tunas let me show you Let me show you how this works.
Oh.
Oh, wow.
We just have Diana TV.
Oh, I can look around.
Okay, good.
Let me show you how this works.
Sit down and watch his TV.
Oh, my gosh.
Look at the cat on the wall.
And the Among Us.
Nice.
Diana Vision.
Let's upgrade.
Upgrade, upgrade.
I kind of want to upgrade to my gun.
It's 44 to 49 damage seems pretty good.
I think.
We can only upgrade one thing, though.
More gun.
It's a lot of damage.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Oh, defense units.
Defense units are a class of weapons designed to overpower
opponents.
Use skillfully.
Turn a fight.
Helping against tough enemies or obstacles.
Performance skills according to upgrade level.
Yahoo!
Oh, here we go.
They look just like yours.
Oh, we can do more of the duration for the decoy.
Octopus.
Do you attend to 100% the zone and get the other REM, or
will you go straight to the boss?
I think we'll go to the boss.
Actually, my head is starting to hurt.
So, I don't know.
I feel like maybe like I've been having to do a lot of
stuff, a lot of work off stream.
So, I apologize.
It's kind of run me a little, you know.
Let's do...
Oh, we were gonna do...
Was I gonna do thrusters?
We could do thrusters.
drive.
You can call it here.
I think I want to beat the boss.
Am I close to the boss?
To the boss of this level?
Because I think if I am, then...
I'm getting no sleep is hard too.
Yeah, I didn't get much sleep.
I'm close?
Okay, cool.
We'll go do the boss then.
Let's do a thruster then.
I think that might be good for us.
It might be good for a boss to dodge a lot.
so we'll do that yeah yeah yeah yeah okay oh and our coins
we're so close to maxing this out actually we'll get the
bingo we'll get double bingo wait a second i'm gonna get
double bingo oh you have quite the eye organ bingo oh wait
anything would be bingo This would be double bingo.
Wait, that's what I said.
Wait.
So, this would not be double bingo.
This would be one bingo.
We'll do this one for double bingo.
Triple bingo.
Triple?
What did I?
How would you mean I did a triple bingo?
I thought I only did a double bingo.
Hacking note that this was...
enemy act actuators temporarily stopping their movements
repeated use on the same enemy reduces its effectiveness
passing through multiple nodes of the same type extends its
duration oh wait repeated use on the same okay okay okay
nice we'll come back and do the next one that's a good one I
think so too, honestly.
We hope you enjoy your purchase.
Thank you very much.
Triple bingo.
We also have new info here.
On these guys, the walkers.
But honestly, I love the way they look.
When they're all opened up.
They look so cool.
Oh, their hands.
It's not blood, right?
No, it's too shiny.
I don't have their toes, too.
They look so cool.
Even if they have giant necks.
How long that neck is.
Wow.
Cool.
It's playtime.
No, Diana, it's go time.
It's go time.
We gotta go.
Let's, uh...
Weapon loadout.
Do our thing.
And then for the hacking nodes.
Maybe we...
I don't know.
I think maybe the decode.
For the freeze?
Wait till you see this boss.
Oh, I'm excited.
I feel like people, not you, people overall, are
speedrunning this game too much.
and say that the plot is basic.
The whole Luna filament and copying theme is fascinating.
I've been having fun taking my time with the game.
I take my time with every game, though.
You don't need multi-pack on boss?
Okay.
Good to know.
I wasn't sure if they would summon some guys.
But if it doesn't seem like they will, then that's okay.
I mean, we can still get them.
Chargeable weapons charge 30% faster.
I think I'm still gonna keep what I have?
Maybe.
Open enemies stay exposed for 15% longer.
Maybe we do that instead.
10 meters is pretty close.
I probably won't be 10 meters within the boss, I imagine.
Maybe.
But this one definitely increased the hacking range by 30%.
We want that.
And I think just increasing our max HP is always good too.
So...
Yeah, we'll keep that.
10 is not a big deal but this is yeah oh like for health
maybe or do you mean for the aiming i think this is okay i
think this suits what i how i play anyway
i got 45 hours put into prog model holy cow
Nice.
One second.
Ducky, ducky.
Um, this away.
You think I can just run past the babies?
Can I sneak past them?
Eee!
Ew, he was looking right at me.
Yeah?
Easily?
Oh, I have to go this way.
Eee!
Where is it?
Don't come this way.
Oh my gosh, wait.
No!
You son of a...
I'm leaving.
He can't get down here.
Oh, he didn't even follow me.
Stupid baby.
I'm peeking.
I'm just gonna run.
Oh, we can LB here.
Oh.
Nice.
Yeah, we can.
Oh, I thought I'd be able to jump on top of that.
Stupid baby.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Let's get to that tower.
I don't want that guy to see me, but...
What is this?
Oh!
Oh, okay.
Interesting.
There's a whole lot of stuff around here.
Who's that guy?
Who are you?
My overdrive is also...
I just realized it's Mac, so...
That's convenient, right?
I mean, we just did our loadout and everything, so...
Lunate Way.
Anything over here?
Tuna?
70% off, end of season?
Spicy burger.
We know who has all the money in this town because there's
like five ads.
something on the other side
anything anything at all I'm looking around for nothing I
guess maybe
okay geez okie dokie there we go the
boss is not another baby is it like Bigger baby?
I hate you, Edis.
You're annoying.
Acts of violence!
Oh,
oh my god.
It's another baby.
Oh.
Wait, no.
I think the thing is eating the baby.
Ah!
Cool!
Ew!
Um...
Oh, I...
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Oh, that's a stasis net.
Oh my gosh, I thought it was a...
That's okay.
Maybe I can get up close.
Oink!
That was close.
Uh...
Oh, whoops.
Ah!
Wee!
Oh, shoot.
Can I get his tum tum?
We needed to open up his face again.
I wonder if I...
Ah!
What is this?
Oh my god.
Ah!
Let's do this.
Oh!
The jammers, where are?
Oh, I see them.
Oh, is this?
Uh, yeah, we'll do that.
Oh,
wait, I'll do them!
Excuse me.
What's this?
Charge piercer.
There we go.
That's what I was looking for.
And...
Did I miss?
Okay, I think I don't know how to use that thing.
Nice.
Got one.
I got the second.
That's spreading something on the ground.
Nice.
Yeah, that was the auto aim working well.
Oh, I know.
It's spreading its code.
Spread my code.
Oh!
I know.
Oh, my God.
Diana is being very...
Get up on the Hydra's back!
I'll survive.
I'm getting right now from her.
I guess Diana, I think I know that it still has something on
the side.
I need to get on the other side, though.
I mean, I might be able to do it without...
Actually, this is good.
Thank you.
Oh shoot, I'm like all the way on the other side
Oh, take this
Yeah, baby
Oh, I'm like right under its butt Oh, where the hell
It's trying something new!
Oh no!
Ouchie!
Holy cow!
He's huge!
This is some BS.
Oh my gosh, please.
I'm trying!
oh my god he threw a car at me please get up here i can't
tell what to do here
what do you mean higher ground
where here oh my god i'm gonna die i'm gonna die oh i see it
oh holy shit there was a There was like one elevator.
Yeah, he
is.
Maybe I can get the stasis net.
Yeah.
And shoot him that way.
Because otherwise I'm like...
I'm struggling to get him to move.
Okay, that's...
Oh my god, he has...
He has so many more!
Move back?
Oh, okay, okay, you just move back.
Oh, shoot.
Uh-oh.
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
We got this one?
Is he gonna get me up here?
Oh, he destroyed my building!
You asshole!
I had one thing!
Oh!
Come on!
Oh my god, he's gonna get this one too, isn't he?
As soon as I'm up here.
Reloading.
Please don't.
Please!
His reload, bastard!
Oh my god.
Get up on the Hydra!
back it's on his butt yeah oh i got him
yeah oh oh nice go go go go go go go go go go go get up on
the hydra's back oh we got him yeah baby unless round two
built for.
We
got this.
Initiate!
Oh,
damn!
It's okay, there's no fall damage.
Very cool.
You alright?
I fell down again.
Aww.
Hey, don't sweat it.
Teammates look out for each other.
Mm-hmm.
And we're a team, right?
So cute.
Maybe.
That was a maybe.
Diana, the cutest backseater, literally seated on your back.
I just- The comms tower!
We made it!
Yeah.
What's wrong with the comms tower?
Let's go.
I gotta call home.
ET phone home.
Shelter license key too!
We can do more things at the shelter now!
Yeah, we can.
But first, I gotta get in touch with Earth.
Oh, okay.
Wait, but my stuff!
I didn't get to look around!
What are you talking about?
Why?
Dang it.
Denied.
I know.
My loot.
She's so cute.
Denied.
Revoked by Edis.
I can't do anything.
Let's hack.
Come on.
How about here?
The Teradone?
The Terra Dome.
What are we doing?
I got these other stops as well.
There's gotta be something there we can use.
How are we so sure?
I mean, the moon is like all...
How... like, it's all destroyed.
How are we sure that...
Wonder if they're still online?
How are we sure that the...
Look!
It's back!
The cat!
That the trains are working, like they're not destroyed.
Can you hear me?
Please respond.
What?
I'm so glad I found you.
Who are you?
It's me.
Eight.
Eight?
I borrowed this little one to contact you.
It's good we found each other.
You're a survivor?
Oh, she ate.
I was caught in the moonquake.
And it was trapped here.
Oh, in the Terra Dome.
There's no way out.
I can't even move.
No!
You have to help me.
I must get to Earth.
Oh, please.
There's no time.
Holographic cat.
Hey!
Even has footstep sounds.
It's like she knew you.
You two met?
I don't know, but...
What in the Stranger Things kind of name is that?
Wait till you find six and seven.
What if our name...
Was one?
There's something going down.
We are one.
Let's go find out what?
Obi-Wan Kenobi, you're my only hope.
Yippee!
Yippee, yippee!
Oh, we're back home.
A new destination has been added to the tram line.
The Terra Dome is now accessible.
What do we get to add though, to our shelter, I wonder?
I fear the game might take a very long time if we go sector
by sector for stream, so...
So we're good to go.
Let's head to the Terra Dome now, baby.
Maybe I'll...
more than one in a stream sometime.
New functions have been added to the cabin system.
Shelter level upgraded.
Central terminals now loaded with shiny new stuff.
What's the new stuff?
I am replicator gamma now online and ready to serve.
Yeah, not today, obviously, just because, you know, I'm...
Oh, no, new guns, new guns, new guns.
Hacking modes You can now print mode chips to change your
hacking mode Each mode triggers different effects When
enemies are open What?
That's crazy!
For example Offense mode turns open nodes into offense nodes
Boosting the damage of your next hack Wait, that's cool
Confused Offense mode Auto hacking Wait, I'm locks auto
hacking While hacking with LT press R To activate consumes a
small amount of hacking gauge oh but that's so not fun i
mean i'll probably get it just in case of a pinch but bot
scan when an enemy is open perform scan with x to reveal
enemy weak points object scan oh nearby items see this is
what we've been needing
okay fast moves that's the thing that we have before
critical shot i've been using that Nito was a puzzle master.
Yeah, object skin?
I think I'm just going to grab already because it's kind of
something that.
1-0-1-1-1-1-1-1-1-1-1-1-1-1-1-1-1-1-1-1-1-1-1-1-1-1.
Overdrive.
More mod.
Oh.
Now it costs two things.
Two currencies.
That sucks.
I don't have so much cash on me though but upgrade limits
expanded yes oh no yes and no i have none though she just
ate 800 worth of ram how could she what's your update
synchronizing new functions we probably have a new
initiating long-awaited module training simulations oh i was
gonna say curated collection of challenges complete them to
receive cabin coins cabin coins we even have a new stamp
board available for your enjoyment i knew we did i knew it
try our training sims they're less lethal than the real
thing less lethal oh it's here we go lightning speed oh
reach the target area in 90 seconds failure conditions out
of time.
We could...
Do this?
Destroy all storage boxes.
We get Luna Filament.
Collect 7 signal data in 60 seconds.
Defeat enemies with weapons.
Okay.
Survive lasers for 50 seconds.
Failures incapacitated.
Let's try this one.
Okay.
Let's try it.
We just gotta survive.
Lemon Bar will come back!
I'm locked in.
What the hell?
Evil game.
No, no, no, no!
Ah!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch!
Complete without dodging!
Complete without taking damage!
No!
I could have...
Maybe.
Whatever, we got a cabin coin.
It's a panic read.
We did it, though.
We did it.
And that's all that matters.
Wait, what's the new...
Okay, hold on.
We wanted...
Oh, I wanted this outfit.
That's right.
But then...
What's this one?
Hugh outfit...
Cool.
Triple bingo drone hive.
Unit printer will generate the drone.
drone hive.
It will deploy drones around you that automatically counter
attacks?
Expose.
Ready gate key.
Secret rapport.
Cradle infiltration log day one.
We're almost done with...
You have quite the eye organ.
Oh, I could have done this one for more bingo.
But that's okay.
Let's see it.
Let's see if we can get the last coin much appreciated in
one of these battles oh yeah that thing let's see if we can
do the lightning speed i'm just gonna i'm just gonna dash
baby yeah let's see if we can reach the target area in 90
seconds oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh Oh, oh,
oh.
Destroy!
Oh, shoot.
Maybe.
We're fine.
Oh, I almost fell off the edge, though.
We won't get all the boxes.
We're just trying to get coins.
Oh, we have plenty of time.
It's
completed within 60 seconds.
Yahoo!
destroy all the box oh destroy boxes is one out of four what
do you mean melody thank you so much thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you so much we got some more stuff
too and now we can finally complete our stamp club and get
the new outfit
wonderful blackout
yes this is all i ever wanted this is all i ever wanted
hey and now we can go to the cat exo layer
yippee so cute you go girl you go girl Look how good we look
now!
We look so good together!
Yeah!
Yeah, we look good now!
We look so good now!
Yeah, we look awesome now!
I can't wait to collect more little guys.
I hope you guys have been enjoying!
Pragmata!
Pragmata, pragmata!
Um...
Diana gets uniforms?
Oh yeah, she does.
Minto and Aibu.
Wait, you're so right!
That's so cute!
I've been having so much fun with this game!
I can't wait to play more later.
So...
Nekomimi drip.
Yeah!
And we'll continue...
Next time, next time, next time...
Tomorrow will be our stream, but it will be a stream on
Denzetsu Channel, so not on my channel.
Um...
And yeah...
But wait, before we go...
I want to upgrade, I want to upgrade my...
Daughter.
Oh my god.
Thank you!
So much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
Wait, I'm worried.
about your wallet I'm worried about your wallet but thank
you so much thank you thank you for the very big donor let's
do our only
manage to slide in right at the end but glad you're having
fun your excitement for this game is infectious it's so fun
that's it's just such a fun game thank you scuba Phil, thank
you!
You made this night shift more bearable.
I'm happy to help.
Daughter.
And then we'll do our suit next time.
Okay.
I go.
I save.
Save.
And return the title screen.
I want to see if it's any different gun could use more
damage yeah but we have to wait for that upgrade or rather
we would have to do other upgrades nope it's still the same
but it's still very cute fake me thank you thank you ben
thank you again for more pragmata and we'll play more next
week so yes yes yes yes oh thank you guys so much
good night, bye-bye, see you, see you, see you, bye-bye.